48 heures après l'embrasement de
l'église Saint-Georges à Descartes un
périmètre de sécurité est toujours en
place autour du monument du 12e siècle
des riverains dont les habitations sont
toujours menacées par la fragilité de
l'édifice ont dû être relogées alors que
la facture s'annonce conséquente pour
refaire la charpente et la toiture du
site on s'intéresse au devenir de cette
église avec Florent Clavel autour de
l'église derrière moi toujours ce
périmètre de sécurité 48 heures après
l'incendie les fumées ont disparu mais
pas les doutes autour de la solidité de
l'édifice notamment son pignon
particulièrement dommagé je rappelle que
17 riverains ont dû être provisoirement
relogées depuis hier le maire enchaîne
les réunions avec l'architecte les
services de l'État les experts pour
tenter d'évaluer et les priorités en
matière de travaux ça c'est la priorité
absolue on sécurisé tout le site au
moins la proximité du site le but c'est
de permettre à deux familles de pouvoir
réintégrer leur maison et après la
deuxième phase qui est importante et
urgente aussi c'est de mettre hors d'eau
l'édifice puisqu'à aujourd'hui la voûte
n'a pas bougé vous espérez une
reconstruction à quel horizon
je sais pas je suis assez difficile bon
déjà le premier minimum 3-5 ans depuis
dimanche l'église Saint-Georges devenu
star malgré le roi des filets les
badauds les habitants aussi on a échappé
au tremblement de terre aux inondations
mais pas la foudre et je puis entendre
tout à l'heure dans les rues de
Descartes Marc lui était dans l'église
dimanche matin il n'a pas vu la lumière
mais presque tu es à l'intérieur il y a
eu un retentissement ça a fait une
déflagration dans une église un bruit
sur 10 ans je me suis demandé ce qui se
passait la première chose que j'ai fait
j'ai arrêté de ployer je suis sorti
c'est là que les gens m'ont dit mais
vous avez vu il y a le feu qui est là
voilà j'ai découvert le feu comme les
autres d'après les photos publiées par
les pompiers les mobilier est intacte
notamment l'orgue il a été transféré
dans une église attenante quant au Metz
elles auront toujours lieu à Descartes
mais dans une autre église celle de
Saint-Pierre de baleine